Patrick quit while you're ahead it's
really hard it's really hard
hey guys I'm deja with BuzzFeed and I'm
here today to find some answers to a
very age-old question does black ever
really crack have you ever heard the
saying black poker yeah I feel like
black people age very exquisitely a lot
of the time does that mean you're
immortal
it could be we're trying to find out now
I'd be cool just looking at the picture
how old do you think she looks good well
she looks like 25 good good answer her
skin is beautiful if you flipped out in
that panel one of those ages is her real
age I know it's not what you think it is
I'll leave it he's like in a test in
math Paso you're like well I said my
math count 31 but the closest answer is
in the 29 or 30 for she might be 42
because she wasn't bad boys - yeah final
answer why not if I would have forgotten
about bad boys - I wish where she I was
really close to saying 29 I'm gonna go
gosh if you tell me this guy's in his
sixties I'll leave right now
he looks early forties okay this is a
range I'm a happy web King this guy is a
looker you know one day there yeah
uh-huh I've got some gray in the beard
37 years old I say 37 yeah I don't say
yeah BAM I didn't feel good about it but
I got it right I have some of these gene
I would date an older
and he looked like this she's presenting
the skinny arm which to me says she just
graduated college I'm gonna say 35 she's
probably 72 there's no sign of aging on
this like literally nothing about this
picture tells me that she is any older
than I am
only if she's 62 I'm actually leaving
where did I ever say 45 she has to be 45
she has to be so it's 45 your final
answer day [ __ ] come on oh my gosh how
every single person that we've talked
about looks 30 years old good for you
girl
maybe it's just the shadowing on the
picture but like there was like a little
like I can see wrinkles for the first
time base wise she could be freaking to
any age I don't know but I'm like
looking at some stuff like neck arms
there's a little giveaway in a normal
scale I'd say like yeah she's probably
like just like peaked over her 40s but
on the scale that we've been talking
about today she must be 87 she's not 90
there's no way she's 90 I'll split the
difference between all of them and say
83 final answer I think 75 I'm going 75
yeah that's it oh my god oh my god her
face is probably the same from when she
was 21 to now look at her she's amazing
I could understand like 90 and like dog
years or something like oh she's
actually five do you think blacc ever
cracked apparently not well I can never
cry from what you showed me today black
certainly does not crack I need a coffee
why do you think black doesn't crack
we're just like wine we just get better
with time No
[Laughter]